The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today's
lecture is on sorting.
We'll be talking about specific
sorting algorithms today.
I want to start
by motivating why
we're interested in sorting,
which should be fairly easy.
Then I want to discuss
a particular sorting
algorithm that's
called insertion sort.
That's probably the
simplest sorting algorithm
you can write, it's
five lines of code.
It's not the best
sorting algorithm
that's out there and so
we'll try and improve it.
We'll also talk about merge
sort, which is a divide
and conquer algorithm
and that's going
to motivate the last thing
that I want to spend time on,
which is recurrences and
how you solve recurrences.
Typically the
recurrences that we'll
be looking at in double o six
are going to come from divide
and conquer problems
like merge sort
but you'll see
this over and over.
So let's talk about why
we're interested in sorting.
There's some fairly
obvious applications
like if you want to
maintain a phone book,
you've got a bunch of names
and numbers corresponding
to a telephone
directory and you want
to keep them in
sorted order so it's
easy to search, mp3 organizers,
spreadsheets, et cetera.
So there's lots of
obvious applications.
There's also some
interesting problems
that become easy once
items are sorted.
One example of that
is finding a median.
So let's say that you
have a bunch of items
in an array a zero through
n and a zero through n
contains n numbers and
they're not sorted.
When you sort, you
turn this into b 0
through n, where if
it's just numbers, then
you may sort them in increasing
order or decreasing order.
Let's just call it
increasing order for now.
Or if they're records,
and they're not numbers,
then you have to provide
a comparison function
to determine which record is
smaller than another record.
And that's another
input that you
have to have in order
to do the sorting.
So it doesn't really
matter what the items are
as long as you have the
comparison function.
Think of it as less
than or equal to.
And if you have that and
it's straightforward,
obviously, to check that 3
is less than 4, et cetera.
But it may be a little
more complicated
for more sophisticated
sorting applications.
But the bottom line is that if
you have your algorithm that
takes a comparison
function as an input,
you're going to be able to,
after a certain amount of time,
get B 0 n.
Now if you wanted to find the
median of the set of numbers
that were originally
in the array A,
what would you do once you
have the sorted array B?
AUDIENCE: Isn't there a more
efficient algorithm for median?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
But this is sort of a side
effect of having a sorted list.
If you happen to
have a sorted list,
there's many ways
that you could imagine
building up a sorted list.
One way is you have something
that's completely unsorted
and you run insertion
sort or merge sort.
Another way would be to
maintain a sorted list as you're
getting items put into the list.
So if you happened
to have a sorted list
and you need to have this
sorted list for some reason,
the point I'm making here
is that finding the median
is easy.
And it's easy because
all you have to do
is look at-- depending
on whether n is odd
or even-- look at B of n over 2.
That would give you the
median because you'd
have a bunch of numbers
that are less than that
and the equal set of numbers
that are greater than that,
which is the
definition of median.
So this is not necessarily the
best way, as you pointed out,
of finding the median.
But it's constant time if
you have a sorted list.
That's the point
I wanted to make.
There are other things
that you could do.
And this came up
in Erik's lecture,
which is the notion of
binary search-- finding
an element in an array--
a specific element.
You have a list of items--
again a 0 through n.
And you're looking for a
specific number or item.
You could, obviously,
scan the array,
and that would take you
linear time to find this item.
If the array happened
to be sorted,
then you can find this
in logarithmic time
using what's called
binary search.
Let's say you're looking
for a specific item.
Let's call it k.
Binary search, roughly
speaking, would
work like-- you go compare
k to, again, B of n over 2,
and decide, given
that B is sorted,
you get to look at
1/2 of the array.
If B of n over 2 is not
exactly k, then-- well,
if it's exactly k you're done.
Otherwise, you look
at the left half.
You do your divide
and conquer paradigm.
And you can do this
in logarithmic time.
So keep this in mind,
because binary search
is going to come up
in today's lecture
and again in other lectures.
It's really a great
paradigm of divide
and conquer--
probably the simplest.
And it, essentially,
takes something
that's linear--
a linear search--
and turns it into
logarithmic search.
So those are a
couple of problems
that become easy if
you have a sorted list.
And there's some not
so obvious applications
of sorting-- for example,
data compression.
If you wanted to
compress a file,
one of the things that
you could do is to--
and it's a set of items--
you could sort the items.
And that automatically
finds duplicates.
And you could say, if I have 100
items that are all identical,
I'm going to compress the file
by representing the item once
and, then, having
a number associated
with the frequency of that
item-- similar to what
document distance does.
Document distance can
be viewed as a way
of compressing
your initial input.
Obviously, you lose the works of
Shakespeare or whatever it was.
And it becomes a bunch
of words and frequencies.
But it is something that
compresses the input
and gives you a
different representation.
And so people use sorting as a
subroutine in data compression.
Computer graphics uses sorting.
Most of the time,
when you render
scenes in computer graphics,
you have many layers
corresponding to the scenes.
It turns out that,
in computer graphics,
most of the time you're
actually rendering
front to back because,
when you have a big opaque
object in front, you want
to render that first,
so you don't have to worry
about everything that's
occluded by this
big opaque object.
And that makes things
more efficient.
And so you keep things
sorted front to back,
most of the time, in
computer graphics rendering.
But some of the time, if you're
worried about transparency,
you have to render
things back to front.
So typically, you
have sorted lists
corresponding to the different
objects in both orders--
both increasing order
and decreasing order.
And you're maintaining that.
So sorting is a real
important subroutine
in pretty much any sophisticated
application you look at.
So it's worthwhile to look
at the variety of sorting
algorithms that are out there.
And we're going to do
some simple ones, today.
But if you go and
look at Wikipedia
and do a Google search,
there's all sorts
of sorts like cocktail
sort, and bitonic sort,
and what have you.
And there's reasons why each of
these sorting algorithms exist.
Because in specific
cases, they end up
winning on types of inputs
or types of problems.
So let's take a look at our
first sorting algorithm.
I'm not going to write code
but it will be in the notes.
And it is in your document
distance Python files.
But I'll just give
you pseudocode here
and walk through what
insertion sort looks like
because the purpose
of describing
this algorithm to you is
to analyze its complexity.
We need to do some
counting here,
with respect to this
algorithm, to figure out
how fast it's going to run
in and what the worst case
complexity is.
So what is insertion sort?
For i equals 1, 2, through n,
given an input to be sorted,
what we're going to do is
we're going to insert A of i
in the right position.
And we're going
to assume that we
are sort of midway through
the sorting process, where
we have sorted A 0
through i minus 1.
And we're going to
expand this to this array
to have i plus 1 elements.
And A of i is going
to get inserted
into the correct position.
And we're going to do
this by pairwise swaps
down to the correct position
for the number that is initially
in A of i.
So let's go through
an example of this.
We're going to sort
in increasing order.
Just have six numbers.
And initially, we
have 5, 2, 4, 6, 1, 3.
And we're going to
take a look at this.
And you start with the index
1, or the second element,
because the very first
element-- it's a single element
and it's already
sorted by definition.
But you start from here.
And this is what
we call our key.
And that's essentially a pointer
to where we're at, right now.
And the key keeps
moving to the right
as we go through the different
steps of the algorithm.
And so what you do
is you look at this
and you have-- this is A of i.
That's your key.
And you have A of
0 to 0, which is 5.
And since we want to
sort in increasing order,
this is not sorted.
And so we do a swap.
So what this would do in
this step is to do a swap.
And we would go obtain
2, 5, 4, 6, 1, 3.
So all that's happened here,
in this step-- in the very
first step where the key
is in the second position--
is one swap happened.
Now, your key is
here, at item 4.
Again, you need to put
4 into the right spot.
And so you do pairwise swaps.
And in this case, you
have to do one swap.
And you get 2, 4, 5.
And you're done
with this iteration.
So what happens here is
you have 2, 4, 5, 6, 1, 3.
And now, the key
is over here, at 6.
Now, at this point,
things are kind of easy,
in the sense that you look
at it and you say, well, I
know this part is
already started.
6 is greater than 5.
So you have to do nothing.
So there's no swaps that
happen in this step.
So all that happens
here is you're
going to move the key to
one step to the right.
So you have 2, 4, 5, 6, 1, 3.
And your key is now at 1.
Here, you have to do more work.
Now, you see one aspect of the
complexity of this algorithm--
given that you're doing
pairwise swaps-- the way
this algorithm was defined, in
pseudocode, out there, was I'm
going to use pairwise swaps
to find the correct position.
So what you're going
to do is you're
going to have to
swap first 1 and 6.
And then you'll
swap-- 1 is over here.
So you'll swap this
position and that position.
And then you'll
swap-- essentially,
do 4 swaps to get to
the point where you have
1, 2, 4, 5, 6, 3.
So this is the result.
And the important thing
to understand, here,
is that you've done
four swaps to get 1
to the correct position.
Now, you could imagine a
different data structure
where you move this over
there and you shift them
all to the right.
But in fact, that shifting
of these four elements
is going to be computed
in our model as four
operations, or
four steps, anyway.
So there's no getting
away from the fact
that you have to do
four things here.
And the way the code that
we have for insertion sort
does this is by
using pairwise swaps.
So we're almost done.
Now, we have the key at 3.
And now, 3 needs to get put
into the correct position.
And so you've got
to do a few swaps.
This is the last step.
And what happens here is 3 is
going to get swapped with 6.
And then 3 needs to
get swapped with 5.
get swapped with 4.
And then, since 3 is
greater than 2, you're done.
So you have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And that's it.
So, analysis.
How many steps do I have?
AUDIENCE: n squared?
PROFESSOR: No, how
many steps do I have?
I guess that wasn't
a good question.
If I think of a step as
being a movement of the key,
how many steps do I have?
I have theta n steps.
And in this case, you can
think of it as n minus 1 steps,
since you started with 2.
But let's just call
it theta n steps,
in terms of key positions.
And you're right.
It is n square because,
at any given step,
it's quite possible that
I have to do theta n work.
And one example is
this one, right here,
where I had to do four swaps.
And in general, you can
construct a scenario
where, towards the
end of the algorithm,
you'd have to do theta n work.
But if you had a list
that was reverse sorted.
You would, essentially,
have to do, on an average n
by two swaps as you go
through each of the steps.
And that's theta n.
So each step is theta n swaps.
And when I say
swaps, I could also
say each step is theta
n compares and swaps.
And this is going
to be important
because I'm going to ask
you an interesting question
in a minute.
But let me summarize.
What I have here is a
theta n squared algorithm.
The reason this is
a theta n squared
algorithm is because
I have theta n steps
and each step is theta n.
When I'm counting,
what am I counting
it terms of operations?
The assumption here--
unspoken assumption--
has been that an operation
is a compare and a swap
and they're, essentially,
equal in cost.
And in most computers,
that's true.
You have a single
instruction and, say, the x86
or the MIPS architecture
that can do a compare,
and the same thing for
swapping registers.
So perfectly
reasonably assumption
that compares and
swaps for numbers
have exactly the same cost.
But if you had a record and
you were comparing records,
and the comparison function that
you used for the records was
in itself a method
call or a subroutine,
it's quite possible
that all you're doing
is swapping pointers or
references to do the swap,
but the comparison could be
substantially more expensive.
Most of the time-- and
we'll differentiate
if it becomes
necessary-- we're going
to be counting comparisons
in the sorting algorithms
that we'll be putting out.
And we'll be assuming that
either comparison swaps are
roughly the same or
that compares are--
and we'll say which one,
of course-- that compares
are substantially more
expensive than swaps.
So if you had either of those
cases for insertion sort,
you have a theta n
squared algorithm.
You have theta n
squared compares
and theta n squared swaps.
Now, here's a question.
Let's say that compares are
more expensive than swaps.
And so, I'm concerned
about the theta
n squared comparison cost.
I'm not as concerned, because of
the constant factors involved,
with the theta n
squared swap cost.
This is a question question.
What's a simple fix-- change
to this algorithm that
would give me a better
complexity in the case
where compares are
more expensive,
or I'm only looking at the
complexity of compares.
So the theta
whatever of compares.
Anyone?
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You could
compare with the middle.
What did I call it?
I called it something.
What you just said, I
called it something.
AUDIENCE: Binary search.
PROFESSOR: Binary search.
That's right.
Two cushions for this one.
So you pick them
up after lecture.
So you're exactly right.
You got it right.
I called it binary
search, up here.
And so you can
take insertion sort
and you can sort of trivially
turn it into a theta n log n
algorithm if we
are talking about n
being the number of compares.
And all you have to do
to do that is to say,
you know what, I'm
going to replace
this with binary search.
And you can do that-- and
that was the key observation--
because A of 0 through i
minus 1 is already sorted.
And so you can do binary search
on that part of the array.
So let me just write that down.
Do a binary search on A
of 0 through i minus 1,
which is already sorted.
And essentially, you can think
of it as theta log i time,
and for each of those steps.
And so then you get your
theta n log n theta n log
n in terms of compares.
Does this help the swaps
for an array data structure?
No, because binary search
will require insertion
into A of 0 though i minus 1.
So here's the problem.
Why don't we have a full-fledged
theta n log n algorithm,
regardless of the cost
of compares or swaps?
We don't quite have that.
We don't quite have that because
we need to insert our A of i
into the right position into
A of 0 through i minus 1.
You do that if you have
an array structure,
it might get into the middle.
And you have to shift
things over to the right.
And when you shift
things over to the right,
in the worst case, you may
be shifting a lot of things
over to the right.
And that gets back to worst
case complexity of theta n.
So a binary search
in insertion sort
gives you theta n
log n for compares.
But it's still theta
n squared for swaps.
So as you can see,
there's many varieties
of sorting algorithms.
We just looked at
a couple of them.
And they were both
insertion sort.
The second one
that I just put up
is, I guess, technically
called binary insertion sort
because it does binary search.
And the vanilla
insertion sort is
the one that you have the code
for in the doc dis program,
or at least one of
the doc dis files.
So let's move on and talk
about a different algorithm.
So what we'd like to
do, now-- this class
is about constant improvement.
We're never happy.
We always want to do
a little bit better.
And eventually, once
we run out of room
from an asymptotic
standpoint, you
take these other classes
where you try and improve
constant factors and
get 10%, and 5%, and 1%,
and so on, and so forth.
But we'll stick to improving
asymptotic complexity.
And we're not quite happy
with binary insertion sort
because, in the case of numbers,
our binary insertion sort
has theta n squared complexity,
if you look at swaps.
So we'd like to go find an
algorithm that is theta n log
n.
And I guess, eventually,
we'll have to stop.
But Erik will take care of that.
There's a reason to stop.
It's when you can prove that
you can't do any better.
And so we'll get to
that, eventually.
So merge sort is also something
that you've probably seen.
But there probably
will be a couple
of subtleties that come out as
I describe this algorithm that,
hopefully, will be interesting
to those of you who already
know merge sort.
And for those of you who don't,
it's a very pretty algorithm.
It's a standard recursion
algorithm-- recursive
algorithm-- similar
to a binary search.
What we do, here, is we have
an array, A. We split it
into two parts, L and R.
And essentially, we kind of
do no work, really.
In terms of the L and R in
the sense that we just call,
we keep splitting,
splitting, splitting.
And all the work is
done down at the bottom
in this routine called
merge, where we are merging
a pair of elements
at the leaves.
And then, we merge two
pairs and get four elements.
And then we merge four tuples
of elements, et cetera,
and go all the way up.
So while I'm just saying L
terms into L prime, out here,
there's no real
explicit code that you
can see that turns
L into L prime.
It happens really later.
There's no real
sorting code, here.
It happens in the merge routine.
And you'll see
that quite clearly
when we run through an example.
So you have L and R turn
into L prime and R prime.
And what we end up getting
is a sorted array, A.
And we have what's called
a merge routine that
takes L prime and R
prime and merges them
into the sorted array.
So at the top level, what
you see is split into two,
and do a merge, and get
to the sorted array.
The input is of size n.
You have two arrays
of size n over 2.
These are two sorted
arrays of size n over 2.
And then, finally, you have
a sorted array of size n.
So if you want to follow
the recursive of execution
of this in a small
example, then you'll
be able to see how this works.
And we'll do a fairly
straightforward example
with 8 elements.
So at the top level--
before we get there, merge
is going to assume that
you have two sorted arrays,
and merge them together.
That's the invariant in merge
sort, or for the merge routine.
It assumes the inputs are
sorted-- L and R. Actually
I should say, L
prime and R prime.
So let's say you have
20, 13, 7, and 2.
You have 12, 11, 9, and 1.
And this could be L prime.
And this could be R prime.
What you have is what we
call a two finger algorithm.
And so you've got two
fingers and each of them
point to something.
And in this case, one
of them is pointing
to L. My left finger
is pointing to L prime,
or some element L prime.
My right finger is pointing
to some element in R prime.
And I'm going to
compare the two elements
that my fingers are pointing to.
And I'm going to
choose, in this case,
the smaller of those elements.
And I'm going to put them
into the sorted array.
So start out here.
Look at that and that.
And I compared 2 and 1.
And which is smaller?
1 is smaller.
So I'm going to write 1 down.
This is a two finger
algo for merge.
And I put 1 down.
When I put 1 down, I
had to cross out 1.
So effectively, what
happens is-- let
me just circle that
instead of crossing it out.
And my finger moves up to 9.
So now I'm pointing at 2 and 9.
And I repeat this step.
So now, in this
case, 2 is smaller.
So I'm going to go
ahead and write 2 down.
And I can cross out 2 and
move my finger up to 7.
And so that's it.
I won't bore you with
the rest of the steps.
It's essentially walking up.
You have a couple of
pointers and you're
walking up these two arrays.
And you're writing down 1,
2, 7, 9, 11, 12, 13, 20.
And that's your merge routine.
And all of the work, really,
is done in the merge routine
because, other than
that, the body is simply
a recursive call.
You have to, obviously,
split the array.
But that's fairly
straightforward.
If you have an array, A 0
through n-- and depending on
whether n is odd
or even-- you could
imagine that you set L
to be A 0 n by 2 minus 1,
and R similarly.
And so you just split it
halfway in the middle.
I'll talk about that
a little bit more.
There's a subtlety
associated with that
that we'll get to
in a few minutes.
But to finish up in terms of
the computation of merge sort.
This is it.
The merge routine is doing
most, if not all, of the work.
And this two finger
algorithm is going
to be able to take
two sorted arrays
and put them into a
single sorted array
by interspersing, or
interleaving, these elements.
And what's the
complexity of merge
if I have two arrays
of size n over 2, here?
What do I have?
AUDIENCE: n.
PROFESSOR: n.
We'll give you a cushion, too.
theta n complexity.
So far so good.
I know you know the
answer as to what
the complexity of merge sort is.
But I'm guessing
that most of you
won't be able to prove it to me
because I'm kind of a hard guy
to prove something to.
And I could always say,
no, I don't believe you
or I don't understand.
The complexity-- and you've
said this before, in class,
and I think Erik's
mentioned it--
the overall complexity of this
algorithm is theta n log n
And where does that come from?
How do you prove that?
And so what we'll do, now,
is take a look at merge sort.
And we'll look at
the recursion tree.
And we'll try and--
there are many ways
of proving that merge
sort is theta n log n.
The way we're
going to do this is
what's called proof by picture.
And it's not an established
proof technique,
but it's something
that is very helpful
to get an intuition
behind the proof
and why the result is true.
And you can always
take that and you
can formalize it and
make this something
that everyone believes.
And we'll also look at
substitution, possibly
in section tomorrow,
for recurrence solving.
So where we're right now is that
we have a divide and conquer
algorithm that has a merge
step that is theta n.
And so, if I just look at this
structure that I have here,
I can write a recurrence
for merge sort
that looks like this.
So when I say
complexity, I can say
T of n, which is the
work done for n items,
is going to be some
constant time in order
to divide the array.
So this could be the
part corresponding
to dividing the array.
And there's going to be two
problems of size n over 2.
And so I have 2 T of n over 2.
And this is the recursive part.
And I'm going to have c times
n, which is the merge part.
And that's some constant times
n, which is what we have,
here, with respect to
the theta n complexity.
So you have a recurrence like
this and I know some of you
have seen recurrences in 6.042.
And you know how to solve this.
What I'd like to do is show you
this recursion tree expansion
that, not only tells you how
to solve this occurrence,
but also gives you a means
of solving recurrences where,
instead of having c of n, you
have something else out here.
You have f of n, which
is a different function
from the linear function.
And this recursion
tree is, in my mind,
the simplest way of
arguing the theta n log n
complexity of merge sort.
So what I want to do is
expand this recurrence out.
And let's do that over here.
So I have c of n on top.
I'm going to ignore this
constant factor because c of n
dominates.
So I'll just start with c of n.
I want to break things
up, as I do the recursion.
So when I go c of n, at
the top level-- that's
the work I have to do at
the merge, at the top level.
And then when I go down to two
smaller problems, each of them
is size n over 2.
So I do c times n
divided by 2 [INAUDIBLE].
So this is just a constant c.
I didn't want to
write thetas up here.
You could.
And I'll say a little bit
more about that later.
But think of this cn as
representing the theta n
complexity.
And c is this constant.
So c times n, here. c
times n over 2, here.
And then when I keep going,
I have c times n over 4,
c times n over 4, et cetera,
and so on, and so forth.
And when I come down
all the way here,
n is eventually going to become
1-- or essentially a constant--
and I'm going to have
a bunch of c's here.
So here's another question,
that I'd like you to answer.
Someone tell me what the number
of levels in this tree are,
precisely, and the number
of leaves in this tree are,
precisely.
AUDIENCE: The number of
levels is log n plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Log n plus 1.
Log to the base 2 plus 1.
And the number of leaves?
You raised your hand
back there, first.
Number of leaves.
AUDIENCE: I think n.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you're right.
You think right.
So 1 plus log n and n leaves.
When n becomes 1, how
many of them do you have?
You're down to a single element,
which is, by definition,
sorted.
And you have n leaves.
So now let's add up the work.
I really like this
picture because it's just
so intuitive in terms
of getting us the result
that we're looking for.
So you add up the work in each
of the levels of this tree.
So the top level is cn.
The second level is cn because
I added 1/2 and 1/2, cn, cn.
Wow.
What symmetry.
So you're doing the same
amount of work modulo
the constant factors,
here, with what's
going on with the c1,
which we've ignored,
but roughly the same amount
of work in each of the levels.
And now, you know how
many levels there are.
It's 1 plus log n.
So if you want to write
an equation for T of n,
it's 1 plus log n times c of
n, which is theta of n log n.
So I've mixed in
constants c and thetas.
For the purposes of
this description,
they're interchangeable.
You will see recurrences that
look like this, in class.
And things like that.
Don't get confused.
It's just a constant
multiplicative factor
in front of the
function that you have.
And it's just a little
easier, I think,
to write down these
constant factors
and realize that the
amount of work done
is the same in
each of the leaves.
And once you know the
dimensions of this tree,
in terms of levels and in
terms of the number of leaves,
you get your result.
So we've looked at
two algorithm, so far.
And insertion sort, if
you talk about numbers,
is theta n squared for swaps.
Merge sort is theta n log n.
Here's another
interesting question.
What is one advantage of
insertion sort over merge sort?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: You don't have
to move elements outside
of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
So the two guys who
answered the questions
before with the levels, and you.
Come to me after class.
So that's a great answer.
It's in-place
sorting is something
that has to do with
auxiliary space.
And so what you see, here--
and it was a bit hidden, here.
But the fact of the
matter is that you
had L prime and R prime.
And L prime and R prime are
different from L and R, which
were the initial halves of
the inputs to the sorting
algorithm.
And what I said here is, we're
going to dump this into A.
That's what this picture shows.
This says sorted
array, A. And so you
had to make a copy of the
array-- the two halves L
and R-- in order to
do the recursion,
and then to take the
results and put them
into the sorted array, A.
So you needed-- in
merge sort-- you
needed theta n auxiliary space.
So merge sort, you need
theta n extra space.
And the definition
of in-place sorting
implies that you have theta
1-- constant-- auxiliary space.
The auxiliary space
for insertion sort
is simply that
temporary variable
that you need when
you swap two elements.
So when you want to swap
a couple of registers,
you gotta store one of the
values in a temporary location,
override the other, et cetera.
And that's the theta 1 auxiliary
space for insertion sort.
So there is an advantage of
the version of insertion sort
we've talked about,
today, over merge sort.
And if you have a billion
elements, that's potentially
something you don't
want to store in memory.
If you want to do something
really fast and do everything
in cache or main
memory, and you want
to sort billions are maybe
even trillions of items,
this becomes an
important consideration.
I will say that you can
reduce the constant factor
of the theta n.
So in the vanilla
scheme, you could
imagine that you have to
have a copy of the array.
So if you had n
elements, you essentially
have n extra items of storage.
You can make that n over 2
with a simple coding trick
by keeping 1/2 of A.
You can throw away one of
the L's or one of the R's.
And you can get it
down to n over 2.
And that turns out--
it's a reasonable thing
to do if you have
a billion elements
and you want to reduce your
storage by a constant factor.
So that's one coding trick.
Now it turns out that you
can actually go further.
And there's a fairly
sophisticated algorithm
that's sort of beyond
the scope of 6.006
that's an in-place merge sort.
And this in-place
merge sort is kind of
impractical in the sense
that it doesn't do very well
in terms of the
constant factors.
So while it's in-place and
it's still theta n log n.
The problem is that the running
time of an in-place merge sort
is much worse than the
regular merge sort that
uses theta n auxiliary space.
So people don't really
use in-place merge sort.
It's a great paper.
It's a great thing to read.
Its analysis is a bit
sophisticated for double 0 6.
So we wont go there.
But it does exist.
So you can take merge
sort, and I just
want to let you know that
you can do things in-place.
In terms of numbers, some
experiments we ran a few years
ago-- so these may not
be completely valid
because I'm going to
actually give you numbers--
but merge sort in Python, if
you write a little curve fit
program to do this, is 2.2n log
n microseconds for a given n.
So this is the
merge sort routine.
And if you look at
insertion sort, in Python,
that's something like 0.2
n square microseconds.
So you see the
constant factors here.
If you do insertion sort in C,
which is a compiled language,
then, it's much faster.
It's about 20 times faster.
It's 0.01 n squared
microseconds.
So a little bit of
practice on the side.
We do ask you to write code.
And this is important.
The reason we're
interested in algorithms
is because people
want to run them.
And what you can see is that
you can actually find an n-- so
regardless of whether
you're Python or C,
this tells you that asymptotic
complexity is pretty important
because, once n gets
beyond about 4,000,
you're going to see that
merge sort in Python
beats insertion sort in C.
So the constant
factors get subsumed
beyond certain values of n.
So that's why asymptotic
complexity is important.
You do have a
factor of 20, here,
but that doesn't really
help you in terms
of keeping an n square
algorithm competitive.
It stays competitive
for a little bit longer,
but then falls behind.
That's what I wanted
to cover for sorting.
So hopefully, you
have a sense of what
happens with these two
sorting algorithms.
We'll look at a very different
sorting algorithm next time,
using heaps, which is a
different data structure.
The last thing I want to do in
the couple minutes I have left
is give you a little more
intuition as to recurrence
solving based on this diagram
that I wrote up there.
And so we're going to use
exactly this structure.
And we're going to look at a
couple of different recurrences
that I won't really
motivate in terms
of having a specific
algorithm, but I'll just
write out the recurrence.
And we'll look at the
recursion tree for that.
And I'll try and tease out of
you the complexity associated
with these recurrences of
the overall complexity.
So let's take a look at T
of n equals 2 T of n over 2
plus c n squared.
Let me just call that c--
no need for the brackets.
So constant c times n squared.
So if you had a
crummy merge routine,
and it was taking n square,
and you coded it up wrong.
It's not a great motivation
for this recurrence,
but it's a way this
recurrence could have come up.
So what does this
recursive tree look like?
Well it looks kind of
the same, obviously.
You have c n square; you
have c n square divided by 4;
c n square divided by
4; c n square divided
by 16, four times.
Looking a little bit
different from the other one.
The levels and the leaves
are exactly the same.
Eventually n is going
to go down to 1.
So you will see c
all the way here.
And you're going
to have n leaves.
And you will have, as
before, 1 plus log n levels.
Everything is the same.
And this is why I like this
recursive tree formulation so
much because, now,
all I have to do
is add up the work associated
with each of the levels
to get the solution
to the recurrence.
Now, take a look at
what happens, here.
c n square; c n square divided
by 2; c n square divided by 4.
And this is n times c.
So what does that add up to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
Exactly right.
So if you look at what
happens, here, this dominates.
All of the other things are
actually less than that.
And you said bounded
by two c n square
because this part is
bounded by c n square
and I already have c n
square up at the top.
So this particular algorithm
that corresponds to this crummy
merge sort, or wherever
this recurrence came from,
is a theta n squared algorithm.
And in this case,
all of the work done
is at the root-- at the
top level of the recursion.
Here, there was a
roughly equal amount
of work done in each of
the different levels.
Here, all of the work
was done at the root.
And so to close
up shop, here, let
me just give you real
quick a recurrence where
all of the work is done at
the leaves, just for closure.
So if I had, magically, a merge
routine that actually happened
in constant time, either
through buggy analysis,
or because of it
was buggy, then what
does the tree look
like for that?
And I can think of
this as being theta 1.
Or I can think of this as
being just a constant c.
I'll stick with that.
So I have c, c, c.
Woah, I tried to move that up.
That doesn't work.
So I have n leaves, as before.
And so if I look at
what I have, here, I
have c at the top level.
I have 2c, and so
on and so forth.
4c.
And then I go all
the way down to nc.
And so what happens
here is this dominates.
And so, in this recurrence, the
whole thing runs in theta n.
So the solution to
that is theta n.
And what you have here
is all of the work
being done at the leaves.
We're not going to really cover
this theorem that gives you
a mechanical way of figuring
this out because we think
the recursive tree is a
better way of looking at.
But you can see that, depending
on what that function is,
in terms of the work being
done in the merge routine,
you'd have different
versions of recurrences.
I'll stick around, and people
who answered questions, please
pick up you cushions.
See you next time.